hi I'm Erik Bosse and morville
spider-man on ps4 is littered with
Easter eggs and references and since we
here at new rockstars obsessed with all
things Marvel related and digging up
Easter eggs like they're fried crumbs
out of a fast food bag I'm gonna run
through as many of these Easter eggs
that we could find and I should say
spoiler warning since you know some of
these come up later in the game but
let's start out with the locations all
the Marvel landmarks that you can find
by swinging around New York City some
missable some not so much it's not too
hard to find Avengers Tower in the
skyline spider-man says he thinks the
Avengers are away on the west coast you
can also see the buildings for damage
control that's Tony Stark's cleanup
organization and rocks on the energy
conglomerate I also think I spotted the
RAND Corporation building that's a
company of Danny Rand iron fist down on
the street level you can find the
sanctum sanctorum of Doctor Strange cool
window but I always get the feeling
something strange is going on in that
place as well as the wakandan embassy of
Black Panther and the embassy for the
countries in Korea that's the home of
silver sable you can also find alias
investigations that's the headquarters
of Jessica Jones private investigation
company and the offices of Nelson and
Murdock that's the law firm from
daredevil fog welds gym the gym that
Matt Murdock's father trained at Josie's
bar the Hell's Kitchen dive that Matt
Murdock hits up all the time as well as
the secrets bar with no name other
places you can visit include a statue of
lockjaw that's that big old dog from the
Inhumans show that no one watched it
swapped in here for that bull statue in
Wall Street can also visit Empire State
University go empires
it's the fictional alma mater of Peter
Parker and a lot of other people went
there
there's also Clinton mission shelter
from daredevil that's where his mother
sister Maggie works can also find the
hearts clinic that's the home of the
spider-man villain cardiac Chikara dojo
is mentioned in the spider-man side
mission that's the place where Colleen
winged trains and there's also randomly
the firehouse office of the ghostbusters
along with a nearby graffiti mural of a
ghost and if you want to feel depressed
you can swing on over to these cemetery
and pay your respects to Uncle Ben's
grave ok let's move on to the details
that we found in the game's cutscenes
and again spoiler warning since we're
gonna be getting into a lot of the story
reveals here right away in the opening
cutscene there's a shot of Peter
Parker's bedroom
lots of little details you can see a
stack of comic books including amazing
fantasy number 15 that was the very
first appearance of the spider-man
character in the Marvel Comics and
there's a lot of Daily Bugle headlines
of some Spidey villains and you could
see a lot of post-it notes one says call
TS back read job offer that's referring
to Tony Stark
another one says our our suit fabric
ballistic I'm thinkin RR could be
referring to Reed Richards of the
Fantastic Four
later after beating Wilson Fisk
spider-man makes a reference to the
famous upside-down kiss from the first
spider-man movie and then later a lot of
you noticed a possible venom reference
from Yuri you got a black and white suit
this game also has its own Stan Lee
cameo it comes up in a later cutscene
love seeing you two together again
you always wore my favorites and during
the battle with mr. negative when
spider-man stops a subway train we get
this nod to the train scene in
spider-man 2
it totally worked last time and one
final spoiler warning after beating the
game there's a post-credit cutscene
showing Norman Osborn and his son Harry
with a little tease for venom this
appears to be hinting that Harry Osborn
could return in the sequel to this game
as venom now really there are just a ton
of Easter eggs that you can find by
exploring everything in the game so
let's run through these details at the
developers snuck in now to me the most
interesting detail is this movie theater
marquee that reads Mady will you marry
me this is inserted by developers at
their quest of a spider-man fan planning
to propose to his girlfriend but by the
time the game was released the fan said
thanks but that he and his girlfriend
broke up and now she's with his brother
the developers have a patch plan to
replace the proposal with a shout out to
the guys grandmother nice way to keep in
the family bro I'm just kidding this
grandmother introduced him to spider-man
comics it's a really sweet thing that I
just ruined also at the interest to the
feast center there's a wall containing
photos of the real-life developers of
the game there's also a poster for the
services of dr. and her walls those are
of course anagrams of Marvel lawyers
Murdoch and Walters aka Jennifer Walters
g-hold and when you see this you can
hear Peters narration referencing his
old high school bully Flash Thompson
veteran homelessness is down but still
way too high
good thing my buddy Flash Thompson is
doing his best to fix that elsewhere in
this peace center there's a mention of a
crossword puzzle and then you can
actually find this crossword puzzle and
zoom in on it and it's a real solvable
puzzle with Iron Man is one of the
answers there's also a few references to
other games one comes up on a side
mission it's a nod to grand theft auto 4
characters Neko and Roman belli right
Romans ready and we are
running late you can also find a
storefront with the sign tone rater
obviously a nod to Tomb Raider and at
one point you can hear a broadcast from
Jay jonah Jameson declaring this maniacs
you shoot electricity out of their eyes
so walking piles assay it obviously
refers to Sandman
but Nazis made of bees is actually
referenced to a real but obscure villain
named swarm he's a Nazi sympathizer
whose entire body is composed of bees
bees another fun detail spider-man at
one point makes a joke about people
taking pictures of his three chest hairs
through a hole in the suit and then
later when Peters undressed if you zoom
in on his chest you can see precisely
three chest hairs and while we're
talking about sexy Spiderman Easter eggs
one of the greetings spider-man can give
people on the street is finger guns and
of course that's a reference to emo
Peter Parker's cringy cat calls in
spider-man 3 there are a couple Wilson
Fisk details his famous obliterator cane
as well as his cello which he named
after his wife Vanessa in Auto
octavius's lab check out the notes on
his whiteboards throughout the game to
see his descent into the madness of dark
hawk as well as some drawings of the
raft prison and notes about its weak
points in guard rotation we also learned
that Otto gets support from aim advanced
idea mechanics that's an arms dealer
organization that shows a plot in Marvel
Comics and there are also a number of
Green Goblin references prototype goblin
grenades at Oscorp a prototype glider
can be seen at some point and Mary
Jane's visit to Norman Osborn's
penthouse reveals a prototype goblin
helmet some people spotted a code inside
of it that actually refers to the first
issue of spider-man comics that Green
Goblin showed up and looking around this
penthouse Norman also has a Wallace
certificates and distinctions which
includes an award from the Pin
foundation signed by Hank Pym himself
another do you said whenever Rockets are
fired at spider-man if you go into photo
mode and zoom in you can see the
developers printed on the side the
rocket shells guaranteed to kill spiders
also if you stand outside the pizza
restaurant you can hear the pizza theme
music from the spider-man 2 video game
and there is a cameo by a shirtless
spider-man Craig Miller at the costume
party there's just a lot a lot of stuff
that people are finding there's some
sightings of spider-man and venom action
figures inside buildings and then like
electro referencing the ultimate
spider-man 2 game and Peter making jokes
referencing movies like Robocop and die
hard and oh [ __ ] did last summer but we
don't got time for all that let's move
on in the game you can also retrieve
several backpacks that are webbed up
around the city that contains various
spider-man collectables that are worth
mentioning let's run through what we
found one of them contains a business
card for Nelson and Murdock another a
vial of sand that spider-man thinks
could contain Sandman that he does one
unleash and then another a vial of the
lizard's blood then there's this
farewell card signed by Daily Bugle
staff including Eddie Brock who I'm sure
is very happy to see clearly there's
also a Spidey signal as well as a pin
for Spidey squad their YouTube channel
known for lots of coverage leading up to
the release of the game another item is
this drawing by a kid for whom
spider-man rescued a balloon which is a
nod to the lame side missions in the old
spider-man 2 game where if you had to
rescue balloons for kids it's gotta be
at least another item is a piece of the
helmet of Mysterio while another
contains a book called work-life balance
for idiots the author of that book is
dr. Ludwig Lionheart
actually one of the aliases of Mysterio
aka Quentin Beck another backpack
contains some spider-man suit arm
webbing that's the stuff from a very
early design of spider-man suit from the
60s and lastly another backpack in
Central Park there's a gaming device
that looks a lot like a PlayStation Vita
now another big source of fun details
comes from spider-man's social media
feed which you can access through the
map screen so let's run through some of
this cool stuff that we found one
account appears to be John Jameson Jay
jonah Jameson's son the astronaut I
spotted another account called got a
phone Malone probably a nod to better
call Saul from Breaking Bad and his own
show on AMC there's another post by
monster catcher guy posting about
Pokemon go and then there's a hashtag
that everyone uses called everybody does
get one which is a reference to a family
guy Joe
Wow thanks spider-man everybody gets one
tell them Peter apparently everybody
gets one bingo so those are what I found
so far and I'm sure will keep any more
so a comment down below with your
favorite Easter Egg and follow me on
Twitter and Instagram Eddie a vos and
subscribe to the rockstars these kinds
of in-depth Easter Egg breakdowns from
all the crap that you love thanks for
watching bye